[Music]
oh yeah shy
oh I'm gonna do some good okay I do them
good
[Music]
okay let's say bye say bye
love you oh talk about sisterly love
it's really fun to see yeah Kim
Kardashian's daughter's North and
Chicago West have the sweetest sister
moments on Tick Tock everyone gets along
everyone loves each other I'm rolling
with it it's just it is really Zen it
feels really equal and calm and great
Kim must love seeing her girls get along
so well like when they're whipping up
treats in the kitchen making a milkshake
[Music]
my mess
my house is so full but in the best way
it's it's amazingly full the little ones
even trust each other with their hair
I'm gonna do your eyes
oh yeah
[Music]
oh yeah oh I'm gonna do some good okay I
do them good this looks so good try
bye back to our channel it's your
channel North calls out shy because the
profile is actually her joint account
with Mom Kim K they launched it back in
2021. you just gotta roll with it but it
turns out north has been on the platform
secretly since 2020. North has a private
Tick Tock account so we we do uh
lemon drops yeah she's not allowed to
post them but we have lots of tick tocks
I might post one soon I wonder if Kim
regrets allowing her oldest to have a
public account mom hmm
yeah because Mia I'm awake
North this is not funny having kids is
just there's no way to describe it but
it's a lot well we can definitely
describe the West kiddos relationship as
being full of love for each other okay
let's say bye say bye
love you
[Music]